All right.
So now we're going to
romp through a series
of these projects.
And as we do, I'm hoping that
when we look at the team--
the project teams-- that
members of those project teams
will stand up and turn around
so that everyone else can
see them.
So that when we
have the reception
they know who to
go and talk with.
Oh, this was the
little exhibit to say,
we're not going to talk
about enrollment view.
Because we've already talked
And then when we get to the
physics learning outcomes,
we're going to have
a little deeper dive
with that particular project.
But we're going to start
with common competencies
for a master's redesign.
So Matt Miller, Becca Miller--
no relation, sitting on
opposite sides of the room
but working very closely
with their colleagues--
helped the School of
Education get to a place
where in May they
voted successfully
on a curricular reform
for the master's programs
at the school.
And I think it
took a lot of work
and a lot of thinking
to get there.
And I want us to just imagine
some of the challenges here.
A masters student who
comes to the school
could choose one of
13 different tracks.
There are about 700 that
come from master's programs.
And you're just on
campus for one year.
How do how do you think
about a professional school
and education and imagine
each of those different tracks
and educating them to have the
competencies to go out and do
what they need to do in
a bunch of different ways
and a bunch of different
kinds of professions?
So at the Ed School people--
the students, as I
understand it, they come in--
and it's not like undergraduates
coming into a core program
and learning what it is
that they want to do.
They're professional students.
They have some ideas about
what they want to do.
But they come from all
different kinds of backgrounds.
And some people want
to be data scientists.
to be policymakers.
And some people want
to be educators.
to be superintendents.
And there's different ways
that you might come in and want
to use a master's program.
So part of the
curriculum redesign
was a set of
discussions about what
are the core competencies,
that faculty can agree on,
should cross all of these.
But how can we now
using technology, using
what we understand
about pedagogy,
actually think through how to
deliver that in a personalized,
individualized way
for students who
come from different
backgrounds and need
to go into different places?
So it's a tough set of problems.
And I'm focusing
on it a little bit,
because I think it's
a set of problems
that many of our
schools struggle with--
many of the professional
schools in particular.
You have people
who are coming in
and all of these
different backgrounds,
and they need to go out
into these different ways,
but you have to as
a school say what
are these core competencies?
And how might we deliver
education flexibly
in individualized ways
to be able to get them
through and learn from the
time while they're on campus,
which isn't very long?
So how do we allow
learners flexibility
as they're attained the same
professional competencies,
leverage technology and data to
support diverse adult learners,
prepare professionals for an
evolving career in education?
And the key constituents here
are master's degree students,
faculty, staff, and alumni.
And you can see where
they see this process.
Goals by next year.
Launch a first foundational
course, how people learn.
And this is, I think, a
really remarkable experiment--
the how people learn course.
Which I think is a collaboration
with other people in VPAL,
and is being built right now
as an individualized, flexible
program.
And it relates to
all of our interests.
And many people here
have an interest
in what are pre-matriculation
materials that
could be provided before
people even get on campus?
So in addition, they're
thinking about, as part
of a kind of curriculum mapping
project, learner profiles.
How individual students can
identify where they want to go,
what their course
progression looks
like, and the kinds
of things that they
may be taking on in competencies
as they go through the program.
How that as a data source might
relate to other data sources
in the school allowing for
more visibility as you're
going rapidly through
a set of courses.
Hopes for curriculum
mapping at Harvard--
collaborative exploration
and innovation
around personalized competency
based professional education.
So Nearest Neighbors,
also an Ed School project.
Andrew Ho.
This was Andrew's
brainchild, I believe, partly
as GSE faculty member--
partly as faculty chair
of the VPAL research committee.
And some of the
questions are, who
are the students that
are in your class, what
other classes are they taking?
And what should I know from
the faculty members who
are teaching those
classes about what they're
doing in their classroom that I
can leverage and optimize when
I'm teaching in my classroom?
How can we make it pretty
easy and quick for people
to learn from one another?
If you begin to nurture these
neighborhoods of instructors,
can we call--
can we create some coherency,
even more coherency, and maybe
some ways of teaching that make
better use of people's time?
So at the moment, this is
being used by HGSE faculty,
but next year, your school.
So this, like some of the
other projects that Dustin
was talking about,
it wouldn't be
that hard to adapt and to
move into different schools
and different kinds of programs.
So it's in a phase
of user testing.
Can people read
the print on this?
Yes.
All right.
So you can see that the way
this visual works is you've
got the course in
the center, which
is read being your course.
And you can see in
the previous semester
what percentage of your students
were in these other classes.
And what percentage in
the current semester
were in these other classes.
And you can also begin to use
these data to project forward--
to predict what percentage
might be in other classes.
And by June, full integration
of this Nearest Neighbors
visual data set with VPAL
instructor tools, emails
to instructors answering
who's your nearest neighbor
and what do good neighbors
do for each other?
That sounds sort
of Mr Rogers like.
Hopes for a curriculum
mapping at Harvard.
Clear focus on the
question, whose question
are we answering?
Yes, I agree.
And how actionable
is the answer?
OK.
Science advising.
Logan-- Logan is director
of science education
and, as you can see there,
has other titles as well.
Is an amazing instructor.
And the questions here are,
which structures and systems
will nurture and support
undergraduate research?
How do we meaningfully
connect undergraduate research
to the curricular experience?
Which skills and
competencies should we
be fostering and assessing from
students research experience?
Science concentration advisors
are a key constituency group--
undergraduate students
and research mentors.
And from what I
understand, as you
began to think about this work
and this project and making
research experience
for undergraduates
more visible to
science advisors,
you maybe worked with Harvard
College institutional research,
got some data, and saw that 90%
of undergraduates in the life
sciences have done some
sort of research experience
during their time at Harvard.
And in the largest undergraduate
biology concentrations,
70% of undergraduate
research is done not at FAS,
but at the School of Public
Health, the medical school
and affiliated hospitals.
The kinds of things
that you wouldn't
know unless you're making
these sorts of data
accessible and visible.
And then into the awareness
of science advisors.
So this, of course,
raises questions, as well,
about the oversight,
and if we're
capitalizing on
undergraduate research work
that's being already done
in the best possible way.
Goals by June 2019.
A mix of top down and
bottom up data collection
or an undergraduate
research in science.
Making data
accessible and useful
to inform advising about
research and courses.
And hopes for curriculum
mapping at Harvard-- students
make more informed decisions
about the research,
make more connections research,
and the rest of the curriculum.
I don't know how we
do that, but I think
it's incredibly important.
And we hear all the time
how important that is.
How do these
research experiences
integrate with the
rest of the curriculum?
So I'm now going to
step down and let
us have a little
break from my droning
on and hear a little bit more
depth from Logan and Louis
about this last in this category
of the curriculum mapping
projects.